in america who's got a dick on his arm
and he asked the doctors to put it there
yeah it's what it is he's got a dick in
his arm and apparently he's doing
japanese porn with it
because they blurted it out why did he
why did he put the dick on his arm
what's the point because why the [ __ ]
not it's 2020.
why wouldn't you yeah he suffered a
horrific infection in his perineum that
turned his fingers toes in manhood black
yeah so he decided when i saw my penis
go black i was besides myself
it was in a horror film because when his
penis went black did it grow
yeah i don't know that was a stupid
penis joke about my guys having big
penises
i cannot believe it's racist that his
penis turned black and then he cut it
off that's racist
that is raised but he dropped it yeah i
mean this k i mean this kid looks like a
british kid
this kid looks like he's on the runway
anyway yeah it's what he's 45 years old
he's your age
this kid's 45 yeah he's he's
yeah he's not in good shape for 45. he's
not greek
is what it is he's also wearing he's
also wearing [ __ ] phylene's basement
adidas
you always see what you can tell the the
the cheap version of the adidas that
they got the filings basement store
let's work i'm ready to work i am ready
as well
just a little delay work it girl you
better worry
[Music]
elm stools i don't have to yas anymore i
get
all of the gay out while we work it's
what it is so let's lead it off with
good vibrations tony braxton one of my
favorite singers
reveals secrets our flawless skin is a
vibrator and she holds device to her
face and it says bizarre video
but i say it holds her face an awesome
video
i mean here she is wow um tony haven't
seen tony in a while she also lost
all her money some remember she had lost
all her money that was a big story her
face looks like it's made out of plastic
too if i'm going to be honest with you
yeah i mean if you want i agree with you
it looks like the girls had a few
surgeries to really botox down
yeah let's watch this video but i do
love tony braxton yeah oh
man
[Music]
hold on hold on hold on pause it for a
second i'll pause it for a second i
really want to see if me and you could
try to sing good you
why don't you try one and then i'll try
i got i got uh some stuck in my throat
okay i'll try uh this is the best i can
sing
unbreak my heart
[Music]
say you love me again there
comes with the tears in your eyes when
you come into the
height that's the best i can sing i'm
not lying i wasn't doing that for funny
all right am i a good singer yeah
okay this is what tony said
face tingler just tingles the muscles in
my face and get them activated and work
it
i haven't used it on anything else other
than my face
okay just fyi let's take this and get
the little ball here which is perfect
sometimes i put it in the freezer
it's really cold i just kind of rub it
and it just activates
all those muscles get them together we
are working today we are going to be
cheating today
let's see what sam has for me sam
i named all my wigs so that's to look
and i would suggest long hair i love a
nice hoop i think it kind of modernizes
everything up
to the face and i like to poke him out
just a little bit super saiyan one
and how old is tony braxton are you
ready for my close-up mr
mr devel unbreak my heart
say you love me again because this is
the only morning show where your
daughter wakes up and you have to put on
the movie the descendants
live on the air it's what it is i hope
you enjoyed that episode of our morning
show
wampa in the morning it's the morning
show with fumare
bed head all that it's a little bump of
coke to start your day
me and chris the history hyenas we do
the show live
monday through friday 9 00 a.m eastern
if you want to watch it live
or get access to it every day go join at
patreon.com
bay ridge boys it's our channel sign up
at the lowest tier level till july 1st
and then it changes to the 10 level
either way go
now go now